let's go to our caller from the 7:08
area code color from 708 what's your
name where you calling from hi david
glenn calling from st. Louis how you
doing good what's up Glenn I'm just
wondering you say today you still you
think that the United States is doing
the worst on a car virus situation
wandering through still think on that
even though a lot of European countries
have higher death rate and I know we're
on per-capita not doing as great testing
volume but we are doing better than
France I believe and when you put that
statement ours confuse how you would
actually think do you have to be worse
than China when China was the one who
let it like spread and kind of lied to
the world of health organization if you
want to go into how to extended a lie
but kind of seem like they probably
would have the worst handling out of any
country okay please try to keep the
phone a little further from your mouth
because you are clipping so you there's
a lot of different stuff there that you
mentioned so let's let's step back for a
little bit one thing is I in my if
you're referring to my tweet I actually
said we don't know the truth about the
situation in China so it's hard to
compare our response to China's response
because clearly China has not been
honest about it so I made that caveat so
I don't know would've been the worse
than it there if we know they're not
being true about it right from there I
don't know what the truth is of the
Chinese response because we just don't
know they're certainly being dishonest
that we can say I don't know exactly how
bad their response has been in terms of
other countries it's becoming very clear
that Russia and Brazil are doing very
very poorly they seem to have benefitted
early from the fact that it came first
to the US but Russia and Brazil's curves
are disastrous so by the time it's that
what's difficult about this is the the
outbreak started at different times so
we're not necessarily comparing apples
to apples but Brazil and Russia by the
time it's all said and done may
certainly be up there but one of the
things we can start to look at is the
duration of the curve
before you start seeing dramatic
decreases in cases and deaths and
certainly when you look at places like
Spain and Italy I mean South Korea at
the very top of the list Taiwan these
are places that sometimes in a matter of
10 or 14 days reversed the curve whereas
we are now going on you know multiple
months there are states that are now
having huge growth rates like Texas and
others so I'm not saying the US response
has been the worst it's certainly been
of the worst I still disagree at that I
was still wondering if you see it seem
like when I saw some your tweets on your
shows you say no worse it's more curious
about what country we can definitively
say was worse Iran may have been worse
for example China I mean we're doing
we're doing better testing per capita
and better that's raised in France
okay so we're right now we're fortieth
and testing per capita so we can
certainly find countries and say we're
better on this metric than that country
that we can certainly do but I don't
know what that gets us necessarily I
mean no I'm saying like I mean what what
metric you say you're just looking at
the metric of rising rates of who's
doing better who's doing of like what's
doing better there's a whole bunch of
different stuff that you would look at
and and Glenn I mean really gonna need
you to keep the phone further from your
mouth because that the sound really so
we look at a lot of different things we
look at how long after the first case
did testing get up to a certain level
per capita we were terrible on that we
look at death rate our death rate is the
12th or 13th highest in the world you
look at testing per capita we're 40th in
the world there's a whole bunch of
different stuff that that we look at
there's not just one metric okay we are
now I I agree was more than one metric I
I I guess I would say and from what you
said by all and I just I from the
numbers we I think we was in the middle
but I think it's also hard to compare
country to country because not every
country is basically the same 7 percent
of countries
180 countries were like 12th or 13th
that seems pretty bad to me Glenn I
appreciate the phone call I've got a run
we are gonna take a quick break if you
were holding don't hang up because I
will go right back to the phones after
this